nitu movement fueled the national
dialogue on sexual misconduct but
research shows parents may not be
talking to their kids about sex and
consent a 20-17 report from the Harvard
Graduate School of Education found 61%
of young people have not talked to their
parents about being sure your partner
wants to have sex and is comfortable
doing so before having sex it's a topic
Wall Street Journal columnist Elizabeth
Bernstein explores in her new article
how father's should talk with their sons
about sex in the me to era Bernstein
writes about relationships in her column
called bonds
Elizabeth Bernstein good morning thanks
patty I'm not gonna weigh in I'm a
father I want to hear what you I mean
yet I want to hear what you found from
the fathers you talk to well it's very
interesting I wanted to write this
article because I write on sort of
sexual harassment sexual issues
sometimes in my column and a lot of
fathers were writing and saying several
things one I don't know how to talk
about this but one thing that was
troubling is they were writing and
saying how do I protect my son from
girls there's so many false reports and
that just isn't true it's just not a
true there's not a rash of false reports
where girls are accusing boys of
misconduct that are is not right so I
wanted to give some information to
fathers and sort of shed some light on
this issue were you hearing that
Elizabeth before the recent Kavanagh
conversation was in the culture with
Kavanagh
it was within me - yes it was coming up
as me - over the last year or two has
come up and been a big dialogue it was
coming up and but but Cavanaugh yes if
you say we'll have to talk about assault
and consent because most people believe
that assaults happen in the dark by a
stranger that jumps out that's why kids
should know what assault means and what
consent means as we all grew up that was
the big issue there was danger from
diseases or AIDS but also that the
assault was going to come at you from a
dark corner a parking garage or a street
that was dark don't walk home alone but
that's not really also the full picture
many assaults are somebody the person
knows yeah they know and this is new
terrain for parents as well because
maybe in their generation the major
issues were safe sex and how to avoid
contracting aids and sexually
transmitted diseases correct
so that's how we grew up we also grew up
people it's very uncomfortable to talk
about this many today's fathers their
fathers didn't talk to them and so one
of the experts told me you know you
father how you were fathered so if you
if you didn't learn how to have this
conversation how do we really know how
to have it so is that one of things I
liked about your piece too is that you
didn't just explain the problem you
offered some solutions here and there's
a whole list of how actually to do that
some of the conversations that you have
talk early and often look for teaching
moments you also say focus on values and
self-respect
that's not something new that's been by
good parents talk with two kids for a
long time all the time and just not
around this area again the conversation
is difficult so to focus it in you know
if you a boy should respect himself and
understand I want to be the type of boy
and man who respects women this
conversation came up much in the way it
did in my house when the president was
was boasting about sexual assault on the
Hollywood in the Access Hollywood tape
and not only the boasting about it but
then calling it locker room talk as if
that made it somehow
okay did you find that that conversation
and the way we talk about it in other
words this isn't something to joke about
this isn't something that's in some
protected space to talk about joking
about sexual assault did that come up
Macchi sure because our children are
watching what's going on out there right
and they're also watching whether we're
speaking about it whether we're talking
about it and so a lot of uncomfortable
conversations had to come up but yes the
fathers are saying how in this era and
mothers to how do we talk to our
children they're hearing words on TV
that are coming out of our leaders
mouths like how do they know how do we
know what to say to our children it's a
lot of confusion out there yeah well
you're our article is starting the
conversational is observing thank you so
much thank you